hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and I'm gonna be
restoring this bearded axe from Slovenia
and I'm gonna do it without any power
tools
[Music]
I love doing these acts restoration
projects and I've already done a couple
this year and so check the video
description for links to some of our
other videos but this one's gonna be
special this project is special for two
reasons first off this axe head is so
cool
it's a bearded axe from Slovenia and I'm
gonna do it without any power tools you
know I can sympathize with you guys out
there who don't have workshops who don't
have the budget or the space for a lot
of fancy tools and you want to do these
projects but at an entry level and you
can do it you can totally do it the
first thing we're gonna do with this is
we've got to get the raw stuff now
normally I'd use an angle grinder but
because we're not using power tools
today I'm going to be using vinegar
instead I've got myself a five-gallon
bucket and a gallon of distilled white
vinegar you can use any sort of cooking
vinegar apple vinegar white vinegar rice
vinegar whatever okay it's 5% acidity
that's about the strength you want and
we are gonna put this sucker in the
bottom of the bucket and we're gonna
cover it in vinegar
whoo smells powerful all right I'm just
gonna let that sit for a while and we're
gonna start knocking that rust off so we
left this soak overnight take a look at
it well it's a little better but you can
definitely see that the rust is coming
off there's plenty of rough still on
there so I'm gonna put it back in the
vinegar and let it sit for a while but
twelve hours in the vinegar definitely
loosened some things
it's been 24 hours let's see what we've
got
well definitely there's some improvement
let's go put this in the vinegar bath
for another 24 hours and I'm probably
losing some acidity here so I'm gonna
[Music]
add some fresh vinegar got a full gallon
in there all right it's been 48 hours
and let's take a peek I think I'm gonna
give it another 24 hours and see how
that does all right it's been three days
in the vinegar bath let's take a peek
no not bad but it's not really making
much more progress yes hit with the
steel brush here well that looks pretty
darn good I got about 90% of the rust
knocked off with the wire brush I just
think I need to just a little bit more
time in the vinegar here to loosen up
some of this more stubborn rust okay so
the axes have been soaking in the
vinegar for 3 and 1/2 days now and
they're scrubbing it with the wire brush
and then soaking it and scrubbing it
some more than soaking it seems to work
a lot better than just
scrubbing it okay so you can see here
we're getting really close to the end
it's been about four and a half days now
this is looking really good here but
these little dark spots just right here
and here those are those are some rust a
little bits in here a little bits on the
edge gotta get it all 100% of it gone
looks really good I think I'm pretty
much down to bare steel I'm gonna go
wash this with some soap and water dry
it off and see if I missed any spots
I've had this cleaned up and out of the
vinegar bath for only about five minutes
now you can see it's already developing
rust is starting a brown hue is starting
to replace the metallic shine that it
used to have so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go ahead and put an edge on
this and once I'm done with that I'm
gonna show you how we can keep it from
rusting up on us because just the
humidity in the air will cause this ax
to rust unless we do something about it
[Music]
[Music]
got a nice edge on this this is pretty
darn sharp and there's a few Nick's in
it and the edge is a little uneven but
fixing that with hand tools is a major
undertaking and when you're using hand
tools you kind of got to ask yourself is
it worth it and why little make it look
prettier it doesn't really affect the
performance of the blade that much you
see here how the axe is already turning
brown so we've got to do something about
that or this axe will just turn into a
ball of rust almost immediately so let
me show you how to prevent rust without
doing a load of leg work and polishing
and all that sort of stuff
all right guys so I've got the axe
sitting in the vinegar bath I'm cleaning
it up getting that new rust off and now
I'm gonna try to blue the steel now
there's a couple of different ways to
blue steel you can use the perma blue
kits and this allows you to do it with
cold steel oh but I'm gonna try a
technique I've never used before I'm
going to be a hot bluing steel with an
oil dip so what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna take this axe when clean it up
really good then I'm gonna heat it and
once it's the surface starts to turn a
little bit of a blue color I'm gonna dip
it in oil and that should give it a very
durable coating now there's a couple
pros and cons with doing it this way one
of the problems is that when you heat up
steel to the point of blue you mess with
the temper you mess with the hardness of
the steel so generally this is something
you only do with fundamental pieces
fittings and things like that I really
want to give it a try frankly I've never
done it and this is a good project for
it so I'm gonna do it I might mess with
the the temper but frankly looking at
the craftsmanship of this thing I don't
know how good of a temper or heat
treating it's got anyway so I wouldn't
give it a go and see
what happens you know it's part of the
fun I'm gonna experiment so you guys
don't have to but if that doesn't work
then you can always use these cold
bluing kits which don't affect the the
temper or brittleness of the steel at
all you're gonna rinse this in hot water
and then use dish soap just scrub it
okay I went ahead and set the oven for
550 degrees Fahrenheit so that should
get it to a blue color I'm guessing it
needs about 30 minutes
all right the axe has been in for about
15-20 minutes let's check it out about
540 degrees on the axe so give it a
little bit more we're gonna get it up to
at least 540 stand in for 45 minutes
let's get this out
look at that it didn't quite blew it but
it browned it that is a gorgeous color
well that ax head cools down I'm gonna
start working on the handle now in the
past you've seen me use a lot of exotic
woods like African mahogany and stuff
like that so what I'm gonna do instead
is I'm gonna use this piece of oak from
a pallet so this is some salvaged oak
here and you can see there it's plenty
thick so that should fit in the axe head
unfortunately it is a massive piece of
oak and I have got to whittle this thing
down by hand
[Music]
there did it I don't think I've been
this tired a long time I'll get that
that's pretty good
[Music]
so it's been a couple weeks since I've
been working on this handle and I still
have a lot of material to remove I mean
they use the saw and the chisel to take
away most of it then I would come in
with with what's called a bastard grasp
and this is going to help me shape it
[Laughter]
really slow going mounting this I'm
trying to get this tight of a fit as I
can but this is a hand forged axe and
the hole on the bottom it's not the same
size or shape as the hole on the top
this fits easily into the bottom but it
won't fit into the top
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's sort of burned distressed aged look
I think we'll match the look of the axe
very nicely and it's a lot easier to do
a lot less time than sanding out all
those wrasse marks so nice little trick
there if you want something looks pretty
slick and unique this oak isn't like the
dried exotic woods I've been using in
the past videos it's soft you know it's
it's not as part of a wood and it's a
little bit green
so it actually compresses quite a bit
and it'll shrink as it dries
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys check this out look at that
that is a good-looking act I am really
pleased with how that turned out that
handle looks amazing sometimes wouldn't
you restore an axe you don't want it to
look brand spankin new you want to keep
the weathered look have an old-timey
patina on it and have all the pits and
dings still in there and then you want
the handle to match and the sheath to
match - this is just really all pulls
together well the whole thing looks just
fabulous well guys here I am at the
testing tree can't do an axe restoration
video without chopping some wood so I
got to see how this bearded axe does
well hopefully you guys had as much fun
watching this video as I did make in it
and I hope it proves the point you can
have a lot of fun doing projects like
this even if you don't have power tools
even if you're on a tight budget well if
you guys enjoyed this video check out my
cool restoration playlist where I've got
a bunch of videos me doing fun projects
like this and also I've got my
blacksmithing video playlist where I
have my blacksmithing projects as well
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you'd like to see
more great videos from the outdoor voice
youtube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video